valérie donc 54 ans oat entrepreneurs
artisans créatrice vous faites de l'art
amérindien
ou on est du tarn je lui dis ya un
instant vous ne roulait pas sur l'or
avant bien sûr cette crise sanitaire
nous disiez vous arriviez à dégager 1000
euros par mois pour survivre depuis à
qu'ovide toutes les foires et marchés où
ils travaillent habituellement est
annulé vous touchez autour de 150 euros
par mois aujourd'hui
et oui quand on y arrive déjà tout a été
annulé donc on ne peut plus du tout
travaillé on essaye de travailler avec
un site
mais bon on n'a pas les épaules assez
larges pour pouvoir le développer non
plus donc c'est plus possible qui
l'avenir c'est une catastrophe je n'ose
même pas y penser
d'ailleurs on y pense plus et je sais
pas je vais vivre au jour le jour i je
sais que pour la première fois vous avez
été aux restos du coeur au secours
populaire depuis un mois pour pouvoir
survivre
ouais merci d'ailleurs on reste du coeur
et au secours populaire on en a besoin
plus que jamais et on essaiera de les
aider voilà le plus possible nous aussi
comme on peu parce que vraiment il ya de
plus en plus de gens qui vont aux restos
du coeur qui vont au secours populaire
et on a besoin d'eux oui mais bon quand
on a décidé d'être maître patron que ça
soit petit ou grand pour moi les restos
du coeur c'est impensable
heureusement qu'ils sont là merci mais
la seule chose que je moi c'est pas une
aide c'est travailler c'est vraiment
travailler donc 20 madame la ministre
juste
j'aimerais savoir qu'est ce que vous
pensez faire pour aider mais alors là ça
va être l'un versent les petites petites
petites entreprises si on est petit
peut-être qu'un peu dead devrait devenir
grand donc je serai bien d'essayer de
faire quelque chose est de voir l'auto
entrepreneur qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous pourriez faire quoi ce qu'on peut
pas rester comme ça moi je suis dans une
situation
fodil à l'avenir demain je suis là
aujourd'hui pour mon fils pour le savoir
qu' il faut que je continue il ya des
fois il ya des pour moi à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui il ya deux solutions
c'est soit on se retrouve des clients
soient joués tire une balle qua non vous
parler sérieusement comme on dit à tout
à fait vous y avez déjà pensé ben ali
mais pensez à vos enfants pour ça
votre fils déjà on peut pas faire ou pas
faire autrement
mon travail est devenu une passion à
l'âge où j'allais ça fait on va dire 30
35 ans je suis dans le commerce et j'ai
eu des hauts et des bas dans ma vie
arriver un divorce ne veux pas entrer
dans les détails on paye les pots cassés
comme on dit mais mon travail c'est
toute ma vie
qu'on me l'enlève à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui je retrouver du boulot
déjà quand vous avez un cv ou ses
marques il a été patron pour votre vie
c'est même pas la peine en plus à 54 ans
je veux faire quoi j'ai toujours dit je
n'ai pas connu le rsa tant mieux pour
moi et je n'ai pas connu le chômage
je me suis toujours débrouillé malade ou
pas à travailler j'ai fait du peintre en
bâtiment je travaillais dans la
sérigraphie je fais plein de choses et
je me suis même pas être assistés mais
là on arrive à un stade où il fait plus
vous allez vous en sortir
vous voyez qu'aujourd'hui même en ayant
toute la volonté du monde
vous n'y arrivez pas on peut pas on peut
pas et puis on aime manger par les plus
gros faut être réaliste donc on peut
parler l'autre jour mais il ya une
personne qui m'a dit alors je pense même
ses avants d'éducation madame quand vous
ferez des prix équivalents aux grandes
surfaces on va dire ben là j'achèterai
chez vous mais comment voulez vous que
je me mette
oui j'ai des 20 30 ans pour faire un
seul bracelet avec la qualité est tout
et je vais pas les vendre ça à trois ou
quatre rôles comme donc c'est pas
possible je sais pas je sais pas a le
son ce sont vos raisons d'espoir
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut garder espoir
pour vous qu'une je tiens mais je tiens
le coup pour mon fils votre fils
exactement quel gamin il a 24 ans il
s'en sort et travail travail mais oui
les pâtissiers chocolatiers d'accord il
s'en sort mais il s'en sort comme il
peut aussi mais il a toujours eu
l'habitude de se battre et de travailler
chez nous on ne veut pas connaître ni
lui ni le chômage ni le rsa mon papa
était chef d'entreprise alors déjà par
respect pour lui qui est décédé
non je travaillerai jusqu'au bout je
ferais n'importe quoi mais il faut que
je travaille
madame amis ce témoignage de valérie je
pense qu'il parle à des milliers de
pensée qui nous regardent ce soir et ils
disent on est dans le même cas que
valérie on veut travailler on veut s'en
sortir mais aujourd'hui on n'y arrive
pas c'est impossible on a beau avoir
tout là toute la volonté du monde
aujourd'hui c'est impossible qu est ce
que pouvait faire pour les petits petits
petits artisans comme valérie d'abord
valérie moi je vais vous dire merci de
sart ce témoignage parce qu'au fond vous
parlez pour les il ya je crois 500 1000
magasins aujourd'hui qu'ils peuvent pas
bosser comme vous alors vous c'est les
marchés si j'ai bien compris on ne fume
pas et je vais marcher on les a on n'a
pas fermé les marchés la partie
alimentaire m'ont affirmé tout ce qui
était au tour donc les bracelets vont
essayer cerveau au sort tout à fait vrai
et par rapport à ça évidemment vous avez
raison de témoigner je pense qu'il faut
enfin dans cette crise qui est
absolument inédite déjà recourir à
toutes les aides
c'est normal c'est pas c'est pas propre
au fait que vous ayez eu un accident
dans votre travail c'est parce que vous
êtes confrontés à une situation qu'elle
des centaines de milliers de français
sont confrontés
des millions de personnes dans le monde
je pense que c'est important qu'on se le
dise aussi c'est à dire que moi
j'entends des gens qui disent mais je
veux pas être au rsa je veux pas aller
aux restos du coeur je peux aller à
emmaüs
oui sauf que là c'est spécifique pendant
la première guerre mondiale où la
deuxième guerre mondiale on a eu des
actes qui était spécifié l'arrêt place
s'est spécialisé en voyant la deuxième
chose c'est qu'effectivement on est là
pour vous aider est ce que vous avez eu
une aide de l'état à un moment ou un
autre nom vieux je l'entends pas dans
votre du tout du tout alors est-ce que
alors justement parce que il ya plein de
gens qui sont dans le cas de valérie qui
savent pas quelles aides de l'état
de quelles aides de l'état ils peuvent
bénéficier dans son cas
quelles sont les aides dans le cas de
valérie vous êtes auto entrepreneuse
savez de votre société depuis combien de
temps non
neuf ans du genre en avant dix ans
qu'est ce qu'elle peut être pas voir
quels recours valérie aujourd'hui
théoriquement aujourd'hui
elle peut bénéficier de leurs du
remboursement parce que vous êtes
arrêter de travailler du remboursement
de votre chiffre d'affaires celui que
vous aviez fait en moyenne l'année
dernière oui mais si ce monsieur sait
que l'année passée j'ai eu un souci dans
ma vie privée est fait exprès comme il
se base sur l'année d'après le mois par
exemple en mars et là je n'ai pas
travaillé jusqu'à de janvier à juillet
je vais pas travailler c'est quoi mais
pour le coup là on est en novembre
et vous aviez du cil d'affaires l'année
dernière on oui donc ça ça le je crois
que c'est le 20 novembre
vous pouvez aller vous connecter et
demandé à bénéficier à vous faire
rembourser les cartes de chiffre
d'affaires par rapport à sa règle tous
les problèmes mais déjà et déjà donné un
peu d'air déjà ça donne de l'air alors
est ce que vous l'avez fait ça non
maintenant il faut s'en est quand on
arrive à un stade où on baisse les bras
quoi on aimait à dire il ne baissez pas
les bras
valérie j'ai bien compris vous vous
dites je vais m'en sortir par mon
travail je suis sûr que ça va repartir
pour vous mais là il faut que vous
essayez mine de rien de bénéficier du
système et que vous fassiez les
démarches nécessaires pour essayer
peut-être de vous donner un peu d'air
alors ça va pas changer votre situation
mais au moins si ça peut vous donner
c'est le cap et puis c'est motivé pour
aller trouver d'autres manières de
d'accrocher les clients de vendre des
bracelets vous mentionnez que vous
essayez aussi les vendre en click and
collect ou sur des plateformes non oui
j'ai ouvert un petit site mais bon
c'était but et si vous n'avez pas si
vous avez pas de communication non ces
satanés vous n'avez pas l'argent que
vous avez pas mal de
pas mal de sites mais juste pour ce mois
mais enfin c'est toujours bon à prendre
qui gratuitement héberge des commerçants
comme vous qui ont une offre et donc
c'est bon pas payer que c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué que ça quoi voilà moi
c'est le site le temps passe et comment
ça déjà déjà elle va bénéficier
donc si vous faites de l'écart de
chiffre d'affaires que vous aviez fait
en novembre dernier par rapport à cette
année votre chiffre d'affaires en
novembre
balas et 0,1 voilà donc la c voilà donc
la liste ou chat d'affaires qu'on a
travaillé un petit peu juillet un petit
peu oui tu travailles a pu faire
quelques marchés de nuit
on pense j'ai été réservée pour toutes
les foires expositions et les marchés de
noël il n'y a plus rien tout est annulé
donc d'aller en tout cas la suivre votre
dossier et surtout garder espoir
vous êtes une bosseuse bah oui et puis
pour votre fils pouvait pas laisser
tomber
il est encore jeune et ou de chaussures
que vous allez avoir des lendemains plus
heureux mais j'espère et valérie on est
vraiment à vos côtés donc il ya je vais
pas rentrer dans le détail mais il ya
les exonérations de cotisations sociales
ya plusieurs choses dont vous pouvez
bénéficier
on peut essayer regarder les prêts aussi
alors vous allez me dire il faut le
rembourser mais on peut repousser le
moment en rambo c'est pas tout filmé
alors l'heure actuelle on sait pas ce
que sera fait demain bien sûr utilisé
pour prendre après celle sans détergent
moi c'est qu'on croit je comprends
valérie c'est ce qui se dit au contraire
si je vais prendre si je prends après ça
va en mettre encore plus de pression
ça va être encore plus compliqué 3 un
gros risque à prendre et que je
prendrais pas quoi